MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you
all very much for coming.
A very special
presentation for you
today jointly
sponsored by Authors
at Google and Mosaic, our
diversity organization.
We're going to have a
special double presentation
by Michael Erard,
linguist and author
of "Babel No More," a
book on hyperpolyglots,
and Nataly Kelly, a translator
and the author of "Found
in Translation," a book about
the business of translation.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL ERARD: Thank you and
thanks for having us here.
This is my first time
actually meeting Nataly,
although we corresponded a lot.
And this is our first time
talking together about these--
and we happened to have done
these two books about language.
And the overarching conceit of
polyglots versus translators
is that, even though the news
about languages in the world
is that they are dying
off at an alarming rate,
there are still thousands and
thousands of languages, which
poses several ways of
dealing with that diversity.
Google Translate is one.
And then there are two other
paradigmatic human approaches,
one of which is
the polyglot --just
learn all of the languages,
learn as many as you can--
and the translator,
somebody who is involved
in import-export business
across a few language barriers.
And so we've set it up
as a contest in a way.
[LAUGHTER]
NATALY KELLY: Vote
for translators.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL ERARD: But I
think the goal over all
is to talk about differences
and ultimately similarities
between the two approaches.
So Nataly is going start by
talking about translators
and where translators come from.
NATALY KELLY: Sure.
And we have a little picture
that I'd like to show you,
a collage of some translators.
And anybody have a guess
as to who these guys are?
They're not translators,
but they're often
called translators.
AUDIENCE: Interpreters
for the deaf.
NATALY KELLY: Yes.
Yes.
So these three all happen to
be interpreters for the deaf.
And the reason
that I picked them
is because you can see
the language that they are
communicating in, whereas
there are also spoken language
interpreters, like at
the United Nations.
And a lot of people
call them translators.
So anyone know the
difference between the two,
translators and interpreters.
AUDIENCE: Simultainious
[INAUDIBLE].
NATALY KELLY: Interpreters do
work in simultaneous mode, yes.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Translators work with
text primarily, don't they?
NATALY KELLY: Exactly.
So the output for
translators is usually text.
And the output for interpreters
is usually speech or sign
language.
So that's the basic difference.
Now, if you had to guess, where
do you think most translators
and interpreters
live in the world?
AUDIENCE: Washington D.C.
NATALY KELLY: Where?
NATALY KELLY: There are
a lot of interpreters
in Washington D.C.
and translators
for governmental
institutions, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Brussels
would be the other.
NATALY KELLY: Brussels, yes.
For the European
Parliament, especially.
Anywhere else?
AUDIENCE: Brigham
Young University.
[LAUGHTER]
NATALY KELLY:
Actually, yes That's
a really good place
to recruit translators
because the Mormons
tend to go on missions
and they learn languages
usually at a pretty young age.
So when I used to recruit
interpreters and translators,
I found a lot of really
good ones in Utah.
AUDIENCE: Monterey.
NATALY KELLY: And Monterrey!
Oh, you're familiar with "the
language capital the world,"
so to speak.
Yes.
So that's where the
Monterrey Institute is.
That's where most of the
conference interpreters
get trained.
And that is also where the
Defense Language Institute
is housed.
So the answer to where most
where most interpreters
and translators are is really
in two main areas of the world.
And that is in North America and
in Western and Northern Europe.
So the market is worth
$33 billion globally.
And about half of that revenue
is generated-- or I should say
is sent to companies
within Europe.
And about 40% percent
goes to the United States.
And the reason the
United States is so big
is actually not because
of domestic reasons
but because of
military linguists that
have been sent into
Afghanistan and Iraq.
So as military
activity decreases,
we'll start to see less
spending on those areas.
So all of these little
frames or video stills,
they come from a video.
If you look on YouTube and
you put "Found in Translation
YouTube," you'll see a video
of translators and interpreters
from around the world.
The answer to where they
are born is really anywhere.
And we're going to talk later
about how they are made.
And I think that's a more
important question when
it comes to translators
and interpreters.
Before I hand to Michael to
talk about where hyperpolyglots
are born and how they're
born-- a lot people like
to ask to ask me, well, how
did you become an interpreter?
How did you become a translator?
I am, of course, a certified
interpreter for Spanish.
And I am a translator
for Spanish into English.
And I come from a very
small town in the Midwest.
Has anyone ever heard
of Mason City, Iowa?
AUDIENCE: It was the inspiration
for River City in the "Music
Man"
NATALY KELLY: Yes.
So Mason City, Iowa
is like a metropolis
compared to where I'm from.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm from Mason City,
Illinois, which
has-- it's about one square
mile and 2,500 people.
So I think that's
good testament to fact
that translators and
interpreters can really
come from anywhere, even
where there's absolutely
no linguistic diversity
and relatively
little need for translation
and interpreting. [INAUDIBLE].
So I will hand it to Michael
to talk about hyperpolygots.
MICHAEL ERARD: So I wrote a
book about hyperpolyglots,
less of polyglots
than hyperpolyglots,
who are talented language
learners and massive language
accumulators.
The floor for this accumulation
is somewhere between 6 and 11
languages, depending on
who's doing the counting
and also what the languages are.
My position is that
these are people
who have possess
a neurology that's
unique or different in order
to be able to do this, that's
something apart just from
language learning aptitude
but that might have something to
with brain plasticity factors,
with working memory and
executive function skills,
with auditory
cortex, the ability
to hear and discriminate
among sounds
in one's own native language
or in non-native languages.
My position is that these
are people who are not born.
And they're not made.
But they're born to be made.
So really there
are-- there should
be larger numbers of people
who posses this neurology all
round us but who never encounter
the right sort of environments
or conditions to practice
and develop what they have.
There are a couple of
interesting but mostly
conjectural theories
that are offered
for what the components of
this particular neurology are
and how often it might
arise and with what
other sorts of conditions.
But those are probably so
broad that science will never
probably explain
really what those are.
But what is
interesting to consider
is that there might
be some genetic link
to this sort of
language ability.
And since the book came
out, I've certainly
heard a lot of people who say,
I have this language ability,
but it runs in my family.
I can do this.
And my grandfather can do it.
And it goes pretty far back.
I come to this topic because
I was working as a language
journalist looking
for stories to write.
And there was a discussion
on the LINGUIST List, which
is an email listserv
for linguists.
And the question
came up in 2004--
who is the world's
most lingual person?
Which seems like a very-- It's
a very straightforward question.
There should be
straightforward answer.
We know how many--- we know
the person who can eat the most
hot-dogs in a minute.
[LAUGHTER]
We know the oldest
person in the world.
Surely, someone has gone
out and met this person
and measured what they can do.
The only organization that
had taken any interest
in massive multilinguals
of this type
is the Guiness Book of
World Records, which is not
the organization you want in
charge of validating claims
about multilingualism.
So the fact that you have these
characters, these people who
are these massive
language learners,
but who were totally
ignored by linguistics
or applied linguistics or
second language acquisition,
even though there are
some characters, some very
famous hyperpolyglots
who were themselves
linguists, was just a huge
hole and a huge opportunity
for storytelling
and actually try
to apply a little bit of
social scientific rigor to it.
So that's what I set
out to do in the book.
Oh, I should have
put this slide up.
These are some of the people
that I either write about and
or met in the book.
This guy right here-- I
spend quite a bit of time.
You know who he is?
Anyone?
Cardinal Mezzofanti
this Italian cardinal
of the 18th 19th
century, who was
so to speak 72 languages,
which is a number that
has a religious
significance because it's
said to number of languages was
created when the Tower of Babel
fell.
This guy is Elihu Burritt, who's
the American, Yankee polyglot,
a guy who was made famous by
the governor of Massachusetts,
actually, because he
would spend 12 hours a day
working as a blacksmith
and then spend
another eight hours
every day studying.
He apparently taught
himself how to read
in 50 different languages,
although his biographer said
it was probably something
like 30 languages.
And if you ever see the
number of languages,
just the size of the
numbers that occur,
so some skepticism is certainly
warranted and welcome here.
So the question,
how are they made?
Want to talk about how
translators are made?
NATALY KELLY: Sure.
So translators are
definitely made.
And the reason I told
you about my background
because you might
wonder how did I
go from in a real
monolingual town to becoming
an interpreter.
And I learned Spanish in school.
And there were lots of migrant
workers in the surrounding
towns.
And so every chance I had, I
would speak Spanish with them.
So from about age 12 to 16,
I was speaking Spanish a lot.
And I became very
passionate about it
and interested in Spanish.
And maybe this is a
characteristic that a lot of us
language nerds have that the
first time I got my book,
my Spanish textbook, I remember
devouring it and calling up
one of my friends
and saying, hey,
do you want to come over and
practice Spanish with me?
And of course their answer
was, no, why would I want that?
Don't call me anymore.
So I realized that not everybody
has that love for language.
By the time that I got to
college, my professor who
screened me said, I
just advise to take
all of your gen-ed courses
in Spanish in Latin America
because your levels is
already really high.
This'll be the way
to challenge you.
So I did what he said
and I went to Ecuador
and I took my gen-ed
classes in Spanish.
And while I was there
one of my professors
noticed she speaks
Spanish perfectly.
And she's a native
English speaker.
So why don't we
have her interpret
for this conference
that's coming up?
And to me it sounded
like, yeah, I
can speak both
languages perfectly.
So it should be
easy for me, right?
So, I didn't know what
the conference was about,
had know idea what the
subject matter was.
And I get there, and
they tell me, oh, this
is petroleum conference.
And so we'll be discussing
mining and technical terms.
And I thought, hmm, OK, I
know a little bit about that.
It shouldn't be too hard.
So a lot of people think
I speak both languages,
I should be able to handle it.
So I get there-- and
anyone here bilingual?
OK.
So I get there, and I
hear terms like-- I'll
give you a couple examples.
OK, so a quick quiz-- All of you
who have said you're bilingual,
I'm going to give you a term.
And you say it in your
other language, OK?
Derrick.
Babbit.
Rapple rig.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Are these in English?
NATALY KELLY: These
are in English.
[LAUGHTER]
So you can imagine,
when I started
to hear what they were saying.
And I'm standing up there.
And, of course,
they didn't know how
to organize simultaneous
interpreters,
so I was standing up next
to them, and I thought,
will I have headphones?
Will I have a microphone?
And they said, oh no,
just he's going to talk,
and you just speak louder.
[LAUGHTER]
So I was completely unprepared,
you know, 19 years old.
And I realized I
am out my depth.
I have no idea how to do this.
And, in fairness,
I did give it try.
But I kept coming across
words that I didn't know.
So I would have to
paraphrase and clarify.
And then I basically said,
I shouldn't be doing this.
And they thankfully
found someone else
in the audience who
was an engineer, who
was very familiar
with the terminology.
And he took over and
stepped in for me.
So that was my introduction
to the world of interpreting.
So a lot of people when that
happens realize, oh, this
isn't for me.
I'm giving up.
And in my case, it
made me realize, wow,
I really have a long way to go.
So I'm going to learn.
I'm going study.
I"m going to really
devote myself to this.
So I did.
I studied a lot
technical terminology,
legal terminology, medical
terminology in both languages.
And I would assert that
interpreters and translators
are made.
They're definitely made.
In a sense, you could
say that some of them
were born too because
there are skills
that you need that are very
difficult to acquire over time,
especially for interpreting,
that your cognitive load has
to be able to grow and grow,
especially if you're going
to be listening
to a long segment
and rendering it back perfectly.
You have to really be
able to retain that
and be able to convert that
information in your head
and transfer it.
I think, actually, that
consecutive interpreting
is a harder skill, for that
reason, than simultaneous.
Once you're skilled
at simultaneous,
listening and interpreting
at the same time,
it actually becomes
like second nature.
Consecutive takes a
lot, a lot, of practice.
So to all the
bilingual volunteers,
thank you for feeling
some of the pain
that I felt when
I was interpreting
for the first time.
How many of you know how many
words there are in English?
Anyone have a guess?
AUDIENCE: Ulimited.
AUDIENCE: 500,000.
NATALY KELLY: More.
AUDIENCE: A million!
NATALY KELLY: A million!
Yes, right on the money.
At least that's an
estimate that's out there.
About a million
words in English.
And most people-- any idea how
many worlds most people use.
AUDIENCE: 2 and 10,000.
AUDIENCE: 100.
NATALY KELLY: Less,
less than 10,000.
AUDIENCE: I said
between 2 and 10.
NATALY KELLY: Oh, OK.
Yeah, so you're actually good.
4 to 5,000 words.
So good guess.
Or good-- I'm sure
you knew that.
And then how many
word do you think
an educated person
with a college degree
uses on a regular basis?
AUDIENCE: 14,000
AUDIENCE: 20,000
AUDIENCE: 5 to 6,000.
NATALY KELLY: Between 8 and 10.
Between 8 and 10,000.
And for some professions,
like doctors, attorneys
who a lot specialized
knowledge, how many words do you
think they use on
a regular basis?
AUDIENCE: Same number,
just different words?
NATALY KELLY: A little more.
A little more.
They use about 23,000 words.
So whenever you're become
specialized in the area,
you learn jargon.
You learn trade language.
So they do use a lot
of technical language.
So any interpreter who's
working in a technical field,
like court interpreter
or medical interpreter,
they're actually using 23,000
words on a regular basis but in
more than on language.
So I think it's really
important to think
about when we think about
skills required for interpreters
and how long it
takes master that,
and for translators as well.
Interpreters have the
additional challenge
for having to have this
information in their head
when they're working.
Translators have to have a lot
of information in their heads
because they have to work
quickly and efficiently.
But they are assisted
by computers.
They're assisted by computer
assisted computer assisted
translation tools,
terminology databases.
All of these kinds of
tools are a standard part
of translators' workflow.
So that gives you
and idea of how
interpreters and
translators are made.
It basically takes a lot of
dedication, practice, and time
to acquire the skills.
MICHAEL ERARD: And that would
be same for hyperpolyglots.
There's no way that you
can get around putting
all that language
stuff in your head
without just spending
a lot of time doing it.
A lot of people
have been interested
and have asked me, so is
there some sort of secret
or some sort of method
that the hyperpolyglots had
that I could use?
Outside of drinking
more Belgian beer.
I don't know if
that necessarily--
AUDIENCE: Isn't helpful.
No I tried.
MICHAEL ERARD: It
doesn't help [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so these are people
who, because they've
spent so much time
learning languages,
they have learned how
they learn uniquely.
So they've honed in on the
methods that work for them
and for them uniquely.
So you wouldn't necessarily want
to use their recommendations
because their recommendations
might actually be bad for you.
They might not just be neutral.
They might actually
be bad for you.
But these people, some
of them are autodidacts.
Some of them take
classes and are
very happy in groups of people.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
what's an autodidact.
MICHAEL ERARD: Someone
who teaches themselves.
AUDIENCE: Sounded
like 8,000 words.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL ERARD: Someone who
teaches him or herself.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any examples
of some of these language
acquisition techniques
that might be good for one
of these hyperpolyglots
but very bad for somebody else?
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah.
So one of the guys
that I interview,
Alexander Arguelles,
there's a YouTube video
of him talking about his daily
linguistic workout, which
involves studying like 20
languages in 20 minute chunks.
Every day he gets up
at 3:00 in the morning
and starts doing this.
He does something
called shadowing.
And I actually did it with him.
And it worked for me too.
But the idea is that you take
a recording in the language
that you're trying to learn.
And you put it on, listen to it.
And you go outside.
And you walk with really
exaggerated gestures like that.
And then you repeat
what you're hearing
at the same time
you're hearing it.
So there's a couple-- so you're
just automatizing the sounds.
And there's something about
link between the kinesthetics
and the acoustics in the brain.
So and then you would go, and
you would look at the text
and actually look at
what is being said.
It also has this
interesting effect
of inoculating you
or neutralizing
some of embarrassment that you
would feel when you are using
a foreign language, since
you're marching around
outside in public.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No wonder he starts
at 3:00 in the morning.
MICHAEL ERARD: Walking in this
Monty Python-esque sort of way.
And a range of--
there was Emil Krebs.
I didn't put a picture
of him up here.
But he was a German
diplomat in China.
And he used to favour
walking around this study,
studying totally naked, drunk
on German beer, in his case,
and working on the refreshing
the language that he was
working on at a
particular moment.
And he used to spend so much
time doing is during the night
that, when it came time to
actually do his translator job,
yeah, he was one cranky guy.
And he was cranky guy anyway.
He was not that
fun to be around.
And there's lots of
idiosyncratic individuals
in a lot of ways.
But made, or born to be made,
they need to make themselves--
and they face a lot of same
challenges everybody else does,
which is, where
you find the time?
How do you have a life
given this pursue as well?
And how do you keep the
languages in your brain?
One of them talked
about her having
a central set of
active languages
and set of languages
that were "on ice"
that they could activate
at any particular time.
AUDIENCE: Why do say they do it?
MICHAEL ERARD: Why
they say they do it?
A lot of different reason.
They're not raised in
bilingual environments.
Some of them are just
clear-- they're clearly
to systems and to patterns
and pattern recognition.
There's a way in
which some of them
have figured out that
there's this sort
of social behavior
called language.
And maybe it doesn't
come quite as naturally
to them as to other people,
but if you figure out
the rules of this sort
of social behavior,
you can actually fit in.
There are lots of different
sets of rules to learn.
When you learn those
different sets,
you have lots of interactions
with lots of different people.
They like to travel.
They like to feel competent.
I think there's also a way
in which a lot of people
that I met --outside of the
fact that they're just highly
verbal-- it's like
there's not enough
time to say everything they
want to say in English.
But there's this
child-likeness, in a sense,
which you take a couple ways.
One is, I want to explore.
I want to be curious.
But it's also like, I don't
want to be a competent adult.
I don't want to be judged
as a competent adult.
And someone who is marked
a non-native speaker
and as a learner of a language,
hopefully, in most situations,
or in a lot of
situations, not at all,
will be accorded a certain
kind of accommodation,
so they don't have to
perform like adults do.
And that's just
some of the people.
There are other people who are--
AUDIENCE: You are
describing what
I feel are a lot who
successfully gotten
through the Google
review process.
[LAUGHTER]
And I think that's an
interesting sort of question.
At point where would
there be more interest
in natural languages and
actual human languages
if there weren't computer
languages to soak up
a lot of that neurology and
systematizing intelligence.
Somebody else?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have one real quick.
So here's a story I
read about years ago.
And I was wondering if
you heard the same story.
It's about this [INAUDIBLE]
in a prison cell.
In the prison cell a
couple men in another cell
were condemned to
die for some reason.
And they were talking
amongst themselves
in a language that he had
heard before. [INAUDIBLE].
He basically acquired the
knowledge of this language
and was able to argue to the
captors about their situation
as it applied to that.
Have you heard this story.
It was back ancient times.
Well, not ancient times--
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah, so I
have a different version
of that anecdote.
Let me do that anecdote
and then we'll move on.
But I heard the
version of the anecdote
about Cardinal
Mezzofanti, this priest.
So it wasn't about
overhearing a conversation.
It was about two
prisoners who had
been condemned to
die in the morning.
And that no one had heard
their confession yet.
And no one could because
no one knew their language.
So Mezzofanti went in and
learned their language.
And then at dawn was able to
send them off to the gallows.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: From listening to them
talk, he'd somehow [INAUDIBLE].
That seems more
believable to me.
MICHAEL ERARD: Oh
what, Mezzofanti?
AUDIENCE: Well, the
story that you told?
MICHAEL ERARD: Rather
than just overhearing it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But there's the
case of Kenneth Hale, who
was an MIT linguist who claimed
to have been able to pick up
languages just by
listening to people.
I mean, really?
I always wondered if
that was really the case.
He's dead now.
So we can't ask.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah,
I've got a whole section
in the book about Hale, who's a
really interesting case of what
happens to people when
certain number of languages
gets attached to their name.
It becomes this oppressive thing
that they can quite escape.
He, actually, himself, said I
can only speak three languages.
He was also a modest
guy, so people
take that to mean that just as
the performance of his modesty.
But if you take it
in a different way,
he was actually making a
legitimate linguistic claim
about his ability.
I can only speak
three languages.
I can talk in many
more languages.
And the ability to
talk in those languages
is actually much
easier to acquire.
And he didn't do
it just by listing,
but did it through actively
eliciting stuff from people.
So the next question
that we have
is how many languages
do they know?
And you have
something like that.
NATALY KELLY: Yeah.
Well, I guess my answer to
this question is-- define know.
So it's kind of like what
Ken Hale struggled with.
I can't really
claim that I'm fully
fluent in these languages.
But I do happen to know
a little bit of them.
And I maybe can navigate.
I said 4 to 5000 is what we
typically use in English.
Or what people use in
English on a regular basis.
4 to 5000 words is that much to
learn, when you think about it.
So you could navigate
in most languages.
But can you say the word
derrick in your other language.
So when it comes to
translators and interpreters
it's not the number of
languages that they know,
it's the depth at
which they know them.
Anybody have a guess as to
how many languages on average
most translators and
interpreters know?
Or let me put it this way,
how many languages they
use for their work.
In other words,
how many languages
do they translate
into and out of?
AUDIENCE: Two
AUDIENCE: Two or three.
NATALY KELLY: I hear five, three
and, the correct answer, two.
AUDIENCE: 1.5.
NATALY KELLY: 1.5!
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, and [INAUDIBLE]
was that only goes way.
So for translators,
for people who
are producing what
kind of output.
AUDIENCE: Text.
NATALY KELLY: Text.
Written.
Yes.
So for translators,
they are generally
going into their
native language.
So generally, it's because
if you want written language,
you want it to sound
natural and native.
There are some disadvantages
to that, actually,
though, because if they're going
into their stronger language
there's potential for
comprehension errors.
But that's the standard.
That's how most
translators work.
So I worked from Spanish into
English most of the time.
Now conference
interpreters-- anybody
have an idea how they go?
What direction they go in?
So they go from their
passive languages, languages
they can understand into
their active languages.
So comprehension, as
a lot of us know--
how many of you have
studied languages
and can understand a lot
but I just can't speak.
And some people are
uncomfortable speaking and not
comprehending.
And so you have
different types of skills
when you're learning a language.
So conference
interpreters generally
do go into a couple-- they have
a couple of passive languages.
And they go into
their native language.
So like a United
Nations interpreter
might be listening
in French and English
and interpreting into
Arabic, for example.
Community interpreters,
interpreters
who work in courts and
hospitals and who are actually
the most popular type of
interpreter, the most common,
that you'll find in schools
and all around, all around us.
They go in both directions.
They have to interpret in
and out of both languages.
So I gave you some examples
of technical terminology,
but you can imagine a court
room anything can come up.
In addition to having
to know all the law
and all the legal terminology
that could come up,
you also have to
know anything that
could come in testimony,
given as evidence,
and all those kinds
of technical test.
They bring in a expert
witness, you suddenly
have to know all that
terminology that the expert
witness knows in both languages.
So one of the big
skills that interpreters
have to have --because it's
kind of impossible to know
everything about a language,
and in fact, in some languages,
you don't even have exact
linguistic equivalents
for things-- is
one of the skills
is paraphrasing, being
able to explain something
quickly and convey the meaning.
So one of the first tests that
I took as an interpreter--
I was being tested
over the phone
on telephone interpreting.
And there was a sentence
that just tripped me up.
It was in my brain.
But I couldn't remember the
word for hardware store.
And this was in the
midst of a long sentence.
I went to the hardware store
and I bought, blah, blah, blah.
So I know all the
other words, but I
didn't remember hardware store.
So I had to say, a place where
you buy tools and materials
for building.
But I had to come up
with that really quickly.
And I felt so horrible
that I missed that term.
But they said, no actually,
that's one of the skills
that you need as an
interpreter, to be
able to do that in
real time, on the fly.
So "Taboo" is an
excellent game to practice
if you want to become
an interpreter.
[LAUGHTER]
So the answer to
this question-- there
are, of course,
interpreters and translators
who do work in more than
just one combination.
And, as I mentioned,
conference interpreters
tend to go a couple
passive languages
into an active language.
But in general the average,
on the whole, is two.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If get all the
conference interpreters
together and all
of the community
interpreters together, do you
have all the interpreters?
Or are there
categories left over?
NATALY KELLY: There are.
There's something
called --I don't
like this term-- but escort
interpreter, who's basically
someone who accompanies
a business person.
What happens is there's not
enough of that kind of contract
work to really keep an
interpreter in play.
Most interpreters and
translators are freelancers.
There are some, of course,
who have full time jobs,
like at hospitals and courts.
But the majority
are freelancers.
So you have other
types of interpreting,
but those are the
two biggest by far.
And, of course, there's
telephone interpreting,
which that was my first
interpreting jobs, which
I interpreted for 991
calls, insurance agencies.
Anything you can
do over the phone,
those calls get interpreted.
I was working at the
time for a company
called AT&T Language Line,
a division of AT&T. So
that's another type.
And video interpreting
is becoming more popular.
I will say, Sign Language,
because of the ADA,
there are interpreters who
work in many more settings
than for spoken
languages in the US.
Under the American with
Disabilities Act, deaf and hard
of hearing individuals
have the right
to an interpreter anywhere.
So their rights cannot
be denied to them.
Now under Title VI of
the Civil Rights Act,
individuals who are not
proficient in English, limited
English proficient,
LEP, individuals
have the right to an interpreter
or translator or language
access, someone who
speaks their language,
anywhere, an institution
or a company that
receives any federal money.
So that means that every state
agency, county agency, city
agency, is required to provide
language assistance to people
who don't speak English.
That's under Title VI
of the Civil Rights Act,
to prevent discrimination on
the basis of national origin.
AUDIENCE: And that's
federal grant, not
federal contract, as in
somebody selling something.
NATALY KELLY: Actually, it
can be any federal money.
So even if you a small
contact, you got a small grant
for like ecofriendly
lighting or something,
you are required, if
someone comes to your door
and speaks another language, to
provide them with assistance.
And usually the way that's
done, because not everybody can
afford to employ interpreters
or bilingual people,
is they simply sign
up for a service,
where they access an
interpreter over the phone.
So that usually meets the
compliance requirements.
So I've answered more than
how many languages I know.
MICHAEL ERARD: You have a table.
You have tracked it.
NATALY KELLY: I do actually.
Yeah.
So this is basically
what I just covered.
Translators-- the format is text
to text, non-native to native.
Subtitle translators, which is
another form of translation--
quite popular,
especially as video
is becoming more important
on the web-- speech to text,
non-native into your
native language.
Conference interpreters--
speech to speech.
Generally, everybody uses
their native language.
And community interpreters
sometimes do text to speech
because if I'm in hospital and
somebody brings in medication
that they brought form
their home country,
I have to read that information
and then render in speech,
so that the doctor
can understand.
So that goes non-native into
native and back and forth.
AUDIENCE: How do you classify
the subtitle translator who's
just going English to English.
text.
NATALY KELLY: Well,
they're usually
just doing subtitle
transcription.
So they're not
usually not grouped
in the same category
as translators.
Usually, not always,
but 99% of the time
translators are going from
one language into another.
There are cases where they go
from a variant into another.
So I've been asked, for
example, to neutralize Spanish
from, let's say, Argentina and
make it appropriate for the US
market, which is largely Mexico
but also many, many other types
of Spanish.
And, believe it or not,
there's a huge degree
of linguistic variation.
We have more than 40 words
for popcorn in Spanish.
And there are lots of
words that mean something
harmless in one variety of
Spanish that means something
completely offensive in another.
And, believe me,
that is a minefield.
So, yeah.
And you have?
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah, ask this
question of how many languages
hyperpolyglots know.
This is the profile of a
European Commission translator,
his languages
arranged in the order
that he learned them on
three different dimensions,
his speaking ability,
his listening
ability, and his
reading ability.
These are all self reports.
I gave him a self report
version of the test
of functional abilities
that the US Government uses.
And I don't have translating.
And I don't have
writing [INAUDIBLE]
that self assessment test
had not been adapted yet.
But you see a lot of variation
across all of his abilities,
even within languages.
And you can see some
biographical-- I mean,
when you know some
n things pop out.
One is that of
all the languages,
he spent a long time living
in a Spanish speaking country.
So even though he doesn't
use that language,
his reported proficiencies
that were fairly high.
And he's also
married to a Slovak.
[LAUGHTER]
He speaks Slovakian at home.
And interestingly,
even though this
is a guy who-- he says that he
translates from 13 languages
into English.
So this is somebody's
who is linguistically
prodigious by one measure.
He working on Chinese right now.
And Chinese is kicking his butt.
He's older.
He's also not just
learning speaking,
but he's trying become
literate as well.
Given that sort of
work that he does,
that would be important to do.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was going to ask,
how do have a proficiency
rating in speaking
but not in listening?
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And what
is the [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I think
it's interesting.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, that's my
experience with sign language.
MICHAEL ERARD: I've know
a lot of people like that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's not
that hard to learn
how to make some of
the sounds but not
be able to hear
them back at speed--
AUDIENCE: That's
impossible for me.
AUDIENCE: --and interpret
it in [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL ERARD:
That's interesting.
AUDIENCE: You some phrases--
AUDIENCE: So how does
Latin come into this?
Because I think it's
the underlying language.
It's called dead
language, unfortunately.
[INAUDIBLE]
But as medical translation, for
example, and medical students
really speak Latin a lot.
So really saying, I'm
translating from English
to you actually knowing
another underlying language,
you have to, right?
NATALY KELLY: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I, mean is
it really that dead?
NATALY KELLY: I can answer
on the translation side.
And you probably have
something to say as well.
Definitely.
Languages with Latin roots often
do use the Latin terms or terms
that are very closely related.
So it's very common in
Spanish, for example,
the words, the roots sound very
technical if you translate them
directly, like the word for
ear nose and throat in Spanish
is [SPEAKING SPANISH].
So you use the Latin roots.
And also like
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
You can say that in English
and it might confuse people
but in Spanish it sort
of makes more sense
because the roots
are still there.
So translator actually have
to sometimes de-Latinize
when they're going from a Latin
language into medical English,
so that it doesn't sound
higher register than it
should in English.
Yeah.
MICHAEL ERARD: In the case
of the hyperpolyglots,
Latin shows up in
a different way.
So a lot of the
historical hyperpolyglots,
you see in their
repertoire, you see
a lot of Latin and
ancient Greek, which
was a matter of the
educational system.
But it turns out that
those two languages
are pretty powerful because
you get access Indo-European
and very old Indo-European
roots and things like that.
Latin-- certainly because
of the lexical stuff.
But the grammar, dealing
with Latin grammar,
sets you up very nicely.
To work with languages that
have also very rich case
system like Russian and other
Slavic languages, for instance.
And so just as a matter of
developing the habits of mind
for learning all of that stuff
and crunching through that,
Latin turned out to
be really useful.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I'm from the Czech
Republic, speaking of.
And I know that the
medical schools, when
study medicine, one year
you have study Latin.
MICHAEL ERARD: Uh huh.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: You hear-- I ask if
it's true that hyperpolyglots
have next couple of
languages a wish list.
Once you decide that this
is something you like to do,
it's like the next movie.
I'm actually a program
language junkie.
I probably don't have
enough skill to actually--
MICHAEL ERARD: Well the
URL hyperpolyglot.org,
I was like, ah, this is cool--
it's for program languages.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I will literally
buy a programming manual
in the beginning of the summer.
And read it until the
return of vacation.
MICHAEL ERARD: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And only a couple
people [INAUDIBLE] so--
[LAUGHTER]
But I have that in
my head, oh, that
would be interesting to learn
that one and that and that one.
Is it same thing?
Did you ask?
Did they say, oh, yeah.
And is it for structural
reasons or cultural reasons?
Are there languages that's like,
that one's really hard so it's
really interesting challenge,
even though I never expect
to travel there, or is it more--
MICHAEL ERARD: There's
all kinds of reasons.
But I think what's important is
that hyperpolyglots are often
criticized or mocked for
having trophy languages--
that once you know
Italian, well,
all of the other Romance
languages are jut a breeze.
So they say that
they know those.
But on the survey that I
did of about 300 people,
I asked people for all of
their languages in the order
that they learned them.
And you actually find people
hopping back and forth
between language families.
So they don't have the
kind of mop-up approach.
They actually switch, which
is based on-- sometimes
they want to explore
historical roots.
Sometimes it's about
access to materials.
So one guy, whose
picture was there,
he wanted to study languages
with historical links
to Turkish.
But all those languages were in
what was then Soviet control.
So all the grammar and
dictionaries were in Russian.
So he learned Russian.
AUDIENCE: So it's funny.
In programming, we also
use the term polyglot
but to mean a program that is
valid in multiple languages.
It's something that
is to the [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah.
Yeah.
And you get similar
kinds of questions.
And I've seen some of them.
Is it possible to
really program?
What does it mean to know
a programing language.
Is it really possible to know.
And I see people bemoaning
the hyperpolyglot approach
because it means that nobody
knows one language really well.
AUDIENCE: Would
you say that it's
typical for a hyperpolyglot to
span so many different language
families?
Because I count at
least five up there.
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah.
They have these repertoire
that are-- Mezzofanti
had something like 11 language
families in seven scripts,
assuming that he was
literate in all of them.
And a lot of them have
that same kind of span.
You're talking multiple writing
systems and multiple language
families.
AUDIENCE: What triggers that?
MICHAEL ERARD: It's a big world.
AUDIENCE: Also I think
term language family
is a very [INAUDIBLE]
active formation.
The difference between a
bunch of languages [INAUDIBLE]
care to admit.
There are language
is more defined
by geopolitical boundaries.
And maybe it's similar
with language families.
I know that in India
Indo-European and Dravidian
languages share so
much common vocabulary.
If someone was really to
slow down a Hindi speaker,
I could probably
understand at least a bit
of what they're saying
in terms of vocabularies.
NATALY KELLY: But across
language families,
sometimes you can
get nothing for free.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's true.
Yeah.
MICHAEL ERARD: Oh,
even within families.
NATALY KELLY: No,
across families.
MICHAEL ERARD: Oh,
Right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I worked at a
speech company before.
And the average
person on our team
knew something like
seven languages.
I felt terrible, right?
Like I knew one and a
smattering of Spanish.
But a lot of it was honestly
driven by where the market was,
like they had a
lot of excitement
that-- I'll bring aboard
Indonesian opportunity
to really learn and do
Indonesian and go over
there and work with
people gather samples.
And so they would get excited
and go to a new market.
It was like, oh, we
can break into that.
And really have a excuse to live
there for while collect data.
It's kind of amazing.
The guy's, yeah, a couple
of weeks got Indonesian.
MICHAEL ERARD: And that would
be sort of the environment
where a hyperpolyglot
would do better.
Someone who was a translator or
interpreter could go into that,
but they wouldn't necessarily
have gravitated towards that.
NATALY KELLY: Not necessarily
MICHAEL ERARD: --given
that their learning
is much deeper in any language.
NATALY KELLY: I think
another piece is availability
of language resources
to learn because--
MICHAEL ERARD: Right.
NATALY KELLY: --I'm
not a hyperpolyglot
but I maybe someday
will become one I hope.
I've studied seven languages.
And I remember looking at the
college course list in Ecuador.
And they have five languages.
And I thought, yes,
I want all of them.
It was because they were
ones that were offered.
That included
Japanese and German
and French and
Italian and Arabic.
And so they were all
diverse but I thought,
I'll take whatever I can get.
If they had offered
Quechua, I would
have taken that, probably
instead of Japanese.
But I think that might be a
driving factor for some people.
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL ERARD: Do want--
we have two topic areas.
Yeah.
We should pick one.
Or ask them to pick one.
Do you want hear about why they
matter from our perspective?
Or do you want to hear
about our assessment
of the future of translators
and hyperpolyglots.
AUDIENCE: I want
do to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Future.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have
leave early anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL ERARD:
[INAUDIBLE] future.
AUDIENCE: Future.
NATALY KELLY: What is the
future of translators?
I guess I really want to
answer the question of why
they matter.
But I will just tell you
that's answered in the book.
[LAUGHTER]
That's what the
whole book explains
is their importance
on our everyday lives.
But as for what's the
future-- I have a chapter
on that at the very end of
the book, in which-- anyone
know the name Franz Och?
The creator of Google Translate?
So I actually interviewed
him in Mountain View
and talked to him about
the future of translation.
I also interviewed
Ray Kurzweil, who
is now a Googler as well--
has since become one.
And I talked to them about
their view of the future
and what what's going to
happen with translation.
So anyone think that
translators and interpreters
will be replaced?
Eventually?
Some day?
It's OK.
You can say if you believe it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Translators, maybe.
But I don't think interpreters.
NATALY KELLY: That's
what a lot people
say because of the
complexity of speech.
And text as much
easier to automate.
There are a few types
of machine translation.
Google Translate is called
statistical machine translation
based on lots of data.
And there's is also something
called rules-based machine
translation, in which basically
you write the rules in detail
for who to treat different
verbs, subject-verb agreements,
gender, all of the
those kinds of things.
And then there's
a hybrid approach
to machine translation.
And there are a lot of
efforts to automate speech,
and in fact Google has
been involved in some.
And some of them
are quite successful
but for very limited domains
and for very specific language
pairs.
And also this whole thing
about speaking comprehension,
these different abilities,
look at computers.
Computers can usually
produce spoken language
much more easily than they
can comprehend because
of all the different variations
in people's speech patterns.
And that might be why you
see some people evaluate
their listening and
their comprehension
lower than their speech
because in some cases
it can be quite hard.
There's a lot of
individual variation.
So the future of translator,
I think, is quite bright.
I follow the market
as a researcher.
And the language services
market for translation
and interpreting has been
growing at double digit growth
rates, compound annual growth
rates, for the last 10 years.
And as more people getting
access to information,
translation is
becoming more and more
and in the translation
community, a lot of people
absolutely hate
Google Translate,
because they think it leads
to really poor translations
that a human could
have done better.
And so they absolutely
cannot stand Google Translate
because of the impact that they
see and people thinking, oh,
well, that's just easy.
You just drop it in
Google Translate.
But I think that
Google Translate
and other such free
services are actually
creating a bigger
market for translation
because it's increasing the
awareness of, oh, it maybe
doesn't have to be so hard.
So what's happening is a lot
of people are using that.
Maybe they put the content
up on their website.
Customers can find them
because of SEO increases.
But then, suddenly,
customers are complaining,
oh, you have a
mistranslation here.
This doesn't make sense.
So then they're actually paying
for professional post editing
is what it's called,
a human translator
cleans up the machine
translation output.
Or they're simply
paying a human to do it.
So that actually
writing awareness,
driving market demand, for
professional human services.
And Ray Kurzweil agreed with me.
He believes that
there is definitely
a point where machine
translation of text
will equal human output,
because, remember,
human output isn't
perfect either.
And a lot that is
very subjective.
But he does believe that
simultaneous interpretation
of speech across languages
will probably not
reach what humans can do.
So that's an assessment
in the future.
MICHAEL ERARD: I
think what's cool
listening to you talk about
the future of translators
an translators is that there are
really no cliches or platitudes
that you touch on or have
to use to promise a future.
But I think if you talk about
the future of hyperpolyglots,
you have to talk about the
world shrinking and access
to information--
lots of cliches.
I think it's a similarly
bright sort of future,
to the degree that people
have better access and faster
access to language resources
and to native speakers online.
So you can actually do
more without getting up.
And I think also the kinds
of organizational and
institutional environments
that use and develop
the hyperpolyglots neurology
are increasing as well.
So those people who might have
that aptitude who would just
be out there and never
get the opportunity
are actually going to
have to that increasingly.
On the flip side
of that, though,
is the thing that came earlier
was the degree to which
interest in programming
languages soaks up---
and it would be interesting
to talk about why programming
languages are more attractive
than human languages.
And I think the boundedness
and the discrete of one
versus the other
is-- and we could
talk about that-- is definitely
what makes one more attractive.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do many of
these hyperpolyglots
make a living at it?
Or is it an avocation?
MICHAEL ERARD: Yeah, so one
of the slides that we skipped
was where they work
or where do find them?
And I split them
into two groups.
There are
institutionalized ones--
[LAUGHTER]
--like Graham.
So they work in an organization
that is multilingual,
where being multilingual
and learning languages
is an expected part of the job.
He has two months
professional development
to go to another
country to learn either
on language that he has
or a language that he
wants to learn.
And he may never
actually ever translate
with that language but--
AUDIENCE: What
organization is he?
MICHAEL ERARD: The
European Commission.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
MICHAEL ERARD: And
that's just expected.
So he's not a dilettante.
He's not considered
in that environment.
And there are
people who are d, So
the guy who did the shadowing,
that marching thing,
when I met him he was
unemployed, doing translation
in Korean.
He's now employed as a
linguistics professor in Oman.
A lot of them are academics.
Some of them are translators.
So one of the ways
in which is there's
a certain amount of similarity
between the translators
and the hyperpolyglots
is the hyperpolyglots,
for exactly that sort
of reason, end up
doing translation work of
various types-- translation
work and not interpretation.
I don't know that I met
anyone who is an interpreter.
NATALY KELLY: Yeah.
Translation if have enough
time and you're not--
maybe if you're doing maybe
not on a professional level
for all languages.
A lot poets, for example,
will translate poetry
because they can basically
find other translations,
compare them, use a
dictionary, use resources.
They have the luxury of time
to really research things
and understand them thoroughly
and introduce a translation.
So it is possible.
Most professional
translators, however,
don't have that luxury because
they to reach a certain number
words per hour in
order to make a living.
AUDIENCE: How many
words per hour is that?
MICHAEL ERARD: Well the average
is about 2,500 words per day.
And that hasn't
changed much even
with computer assisted
translation tools and machine
translation tools
that they're using.
AUDIENCE: Has the
accuracy gone up,
like is that metric
that's measured, right?
NATALY KELLY: You
know there is lack
of measurement of
these types of things.
The market is very
fragmented, so there
aren't a lot of good studies
out there to show that.
But one of the
benefits of using tools
is precisely accuracy
and consistency
of terminology, which is
really important, especially
when you've got your [INAUDIBLE]
guidelines that differ from one
company to another,
companies that
create their own terminology.
And we have a lot of
examples in the book
of this kind of
thing-- translators
for Harlequin romance
novels, interpreters
who interpret for
astronauts, interpreters
who interpret for celebrities.
And translators and
interpreters work in
just so many different
technical areas
that that is an
ongoing challenge
to make sure they have
consistent terminology
and using other sources to make
sure they're, whatever they're
producing, is in alignment
with other information that's
out there.
AUDIENCE: How do they, like,
feed this back somewhere?
Because that's
the important part
to improving computer
aided translated, right?
NATALY KELLY: Yes.
This is the thing.
So most of the files
that they're creating
are called translation
memory files,
so it's basically a
database of translation.
So they have a column
with the source language
and a column with
the target language.
So the tools that
they use will show
them a fuzzy match
or a perfect match.
It will show, oh,
98% of this segment
looks like something that
you translated before.
And it will pop up
and will show that.
And then they can just
simply correct or tweak it
to make it perfect.
So translators amass these
transition memory files.
Sometimes they delver
them back to the client.
Sometimes they don't.
So there's all this data
--I know you guys can see
the problem with this--
[LAUGHTER]
that isn't being
shared with anyone
and is being stored, usually,
on individual personal computers
in people's homes.
And Google actually has
something called the translator
toolkit, which is
designed to help people
be able to store
this and leverage it.
But there are
entrenched providers
that have been
there for decades.
And they tend to use those
tools that are installed locally
on their local computer.
So there is a tendency to
move things toward the cloud.
And I think then we
can harvest that.
Information.
But let's not forget--
one of the other reasons
that people like to preserve
that information is because
of confidentiality in
the a lot of the stuff
that they're translating.
So there is this debate of how
much should go to the cloud
And how much do we we
want to keep secure.
And there's a lot of
discussion about that.
AUDIENCE: That would
be a really cool way
to leak a nuclear secret.
It's like a big secret--
oh, it turns out
we have a translation
for all things
nuclear between [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
NATALY KELLY: Oh and believe me.
There are lots of
interpreters and translators
who are doing that work.
I used to get
recorded transcripts
from intelligence agencies.
Or I would get the
recordings, and I
would have to create
the transcripts.
So this is another variant
that I didn't put there,
where you're listening
and you're transcribing
and you're translating
at the same time.
So and I would hear
all kind of things.
Of course, I didn't
have the big picture
to know what this was
related to-- if you
would harness all
that information.
And the CIA,
intelligence agencies,
have had a really hard
problem with this.
They haven't been able to
recruit enough translators
and interpreters, especially
for critical languages
like [INAUDIBLE] and Pashto--
and even Arabic, which
is a pretty widely
spoken language.
But not everybody
wants to do that work.
So yeah.
MICHAEL ERARD: Well,
thank you very much.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]